welcome to hierarchical clustering my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's WW simply learn comm
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you today we're gonna cover what is
clustering what is hierarchical
clustering how hierarchical clustering
works distance measure what is
agglomerative clustering what is
divisive clustering and then we'll dive
into some code a demo to group states
based on their cells so let's dive into
what is clustering what is clustering so
we'll have a group of people here
hanging out at a table or local coffee
shop I'm guessing coffee shop since they
all have the same mugs and one of them
is trying to figure out what they're
gonna do I have 20 places to cover in
four days I guess he's going traveling
that sounds fun one of those breeze
through Costa Rica or visiting the US or
going to to Europe to go visit all the
highlights
she's got 20 places he wants to go and
he wants to hit him in four days very
ambitious and how will I manage to cover
all of them that's the question that
he's coming up how am I gonna get to all
these different places in the short time
I have maybe he's a sales team so he has
20 places he's got to do demos for you
can make use of clustering by grouping
the places into four clusters each of
these clusters will have places which
are close by so we're gonna cluster them
together by what is closest to the other
one then each day you can visit one
cluster and cover all the places in the
cluster great that's a great idea you
know if you're gonna hit four different
places maybe you're gonna cluster
whatever streets are closest together so
you don't have to travel spend all your
time traveling the method of dividing
the objects into clusters which are
similar between them and are dissimilar
to the objects belonging to another
cluster so this is a formal definition
of clustering and we have here what we
call hierarchical clustering and partial
clustering and we're going to go more
into detail on hierarchical clustering
and you'll see the difference between
the two where partial clustering doesn't
have the descending graph it just has
groups of things and under hierarchical
clustering we're gonna go over
agglomerative and divisive and you can
think of a glamour tip of bringing
things together and divisive as do
finding them apart and then partial
clustering the two most common ones are
k-means that's probably the most common
used for partial clustering and there's
also fuzzy c means and there's other
ways of clustering and other algorithms
out there but these are the two big ones
k-means really being the most common one
used but we're not going to dig too deep
into partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering are pretty
numerous we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of belong
together how do we group them together
we have a social network analysis so
social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest new cells for them
you know this whole group is into Harley
Davidson motorcycles so we cater to them
to sell them Harley Davidson motorcycle
parts and we find out that people in
that group also like leather jackets
they also like motorcycle boots and they
like bandanas my brother's into Harley
Davidson so that's why I picked that
kind of funny example but you can kind
of see we look for similarities between
these people and then we group them
together accordingly and that's a good
city mental clustering is very common in
so many things today we want to know the
sentiments on stocks who's interested in
stocks who's not sentimental analysis we
talked about customer segmentation in
cells well we want to know what kind of
sentimental view people have on
different restaurants if we're going to
open up a new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course City
planning a lot of this I just kind of
aimed at the city planning side sitting
planning is big with clustering we want
to cluster things together so that they
work we don't want to put a industrial
zone in the middle of somebody's
neighborhood where they're not going to
enjoy it or have a commercial zone right
in the middle of the industrial zone
where no one's gonna want to go next to
a factory to go eat a high-end meal or
dinner so it's very big in City Planning
it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models so
when we're exploring data being able to
cluster things together reveal things in
the data we never thought about and then
once we have it cluster we can put that
into another model to help us figure out
what it is we want for our solution so
let's go
little deeper into hierarchical
clustering let's consider we have a set
of cars and we have a group similar we
want to group similar ones together so
below we have you'll see four different
cars down there and we get two clusters
of car types
sedan and SUV so if you're just looking
at it you can probably think oh yeah
we'll put the sedans together and the
SUVs together and then at last we can
group everything into one cluster so we
just have just cars so you can see is we
have this we'd make a nice little tree
this is very common we see anybody talks
about hierarchical clustering this is
usually what you see and what comes out
of it we terminate when we are left with
only one cluster so we have as you can
see we bring them all together we have
one cluster we can't bring it together
anymore because they're all together
hierarchical clustering is separating
data into different groups based on some
measure of similarity so we have to find
a way to measure what makes them alike
and what makes them different
agglomerative clustering is known as a
bottom-up approach remember I said think
of that as bringing things together you
see think the Latin term agloe is
together because you have your glommer
it rocks where all the different pieces
of rocks are in there so we want to
bring everything together that's the
bottom up and then divisive is we're
gonna go from the top down so we take
one huge cluster and we start dividing
it up into two clusters in two three
four five and so on digging even deeper
into how hierarchical clustering works
let's consider we have a few points on a
plane so where this plane is 2d so we
have an X Y coordinates kind of makes it
easy we're going to start with measure
the distance so we want to figure a way
to compute the distance between each
point each data point is a cluster of
its own remember we're going from the
bottom up agglomerative then we have
each point being its own cluster we try
to find the least distance between two
data points to form a cluster and then
once we find those with the least
distance between them we start grouping
them together so we start forming
clusters of multiple points this is
represented in a tree-like structure
called dendogram so this is another
keyword dendogram and you can see it is
it's just a branch we've looked at
before and we do the second group the
same so it gets its own dendogram and
the third gets
it's owned dendogram and then we might
group two groups together so now those
two groups are all under one dendogram
because they're closer together than the
p1 and p2 and then we terminate when we
are left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together you can see on the
right how we've come up all the way up
to the top whoops and we have the gray
hierarchical box coming in there
connecting them so we have just one
cluster and that's a good place to
terminate because there is no way we can
bring them together any further so how
do we measure the distance between the
data points I mean this is really where
it starts getting interesting
up until now you can kind of eyeball and
say hey these look together but when you
have thousands of data points how are we
going to measure those distances and
there is a lot of ways to get the
distance measure so let's go and take a
look at that distance measures will
determine the similarity between two
elements and it will influence the shape
of the clusters and we have Euclidean
distance measure we have squared
Euclidean distance measure which is
almost the same thing but with less
computations and we had the Manhattan
distance measure which will give you
slightly different results and we have
the cosine distance measure which again
is very similar to the Euclidean playing
with triangles and sometimes it can
compute faster depending on what kind of
data you're looking at so let's start
with the Clinton distance measure the
most common is we want to know the
distance between the two points so if we
have a point P and point Q the collision
distance is the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in Euclidean space and you should
recognize D equals in this case we're
going to sum all the points so if there
was more than one point we could figure
out the distance to the not more than
one points this is the sum of more than
two dimensions so we can have the
distance between each of the different
dimensions squared and that will give us
and then take the square root of that
and that gives us the actual distance
between them and they should look
familiar from Euclidean geometry maybe
you haven't played too much with
multiple dimensions so the summation
symbol might not look familiar to you
but it's pretty straightforward is you
add the distance between each of the two
different points squared so if your wide
difference was two minus one squared
would be two and then you take the
difference between the x again squared
and if there was a Z coordinates it
would be you know z1 minus z
two squared and then take the square
root of that and someone or some but all
together and then take the square root
of it so to make a compute faster since
the difference in distances whether one
is farther apart or closer together than
the other we can do what's called the
squared Euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the ik lydian
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end there's no reason to it
certainly gives us the exact distance
but as far as doing calculations as to
which one's bigger or smaller than the
other one it won't make a difference
so we'll just go with this so we just
get rid of that Davitt that final square
root it computes faster and it gives us
the pretty much nucleons squared
distance on there now the Manhattan
distance measurement is a simple sum of
horizontal and vertical components or
the distance between two points measured
along axes at right angles now this is
different because you're not looking at
the direct line between up and in
certain cases the individual distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with Euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the Manhattan distance is you
measure just the Y value and you take
the absolute value of it and you measure
just the X difference you take the
absolute value of it and just the Z and
if you had more you know different
dimensions in there ABCD however many
dimensions you would just take the
absolute value of the difference of
those dimensions and then we have the
cosine distance similarity measures that
angle between the two vectors and as you
can see as the two vectors get further
and further apart the cosine distance
gets larger so it's another way to
measure the distance very similar to the
Euclidean so you're still looking at the
same kind of measurement so should have
a similar result as the first two but
keep in mind the Manhattan will have a
very different result and you can end up
with a bias with the Manhattan if your
data is very skewed if one set of values
is very large and another set of values
is very small but that's a little bit
beyond the scope of this it's just
important to know that about the
Manhattan distance so stick into the
agglomerative clustering an agglomerate
clustering begins with each element as a
separate cluster and then we merge them
into a larger cluster how do we
represent
of more than one point so we're gonna
kind of mix the distance together with
the actual agglomerative and see what
that looks like we're actually gonna
have three key questions that are going
to be answered here so how do we
represent a cluster more than one point
so we're gonna look at the math what it
looks like mathematically and
geometrically how do we determine the
nearness of clusters when to stop
combining clusters always important to
have your computer script or your
whatever you're working on have a
termination point so it's not in going
on eternally we've all done that if you
do any kind of computer programming or
writing a script let's assume that we
have six data points in a Euclidean
space so again we're dealing with XY and
Z in this case just x and y so how do we
represent a cluster more than one point
let's take a look at that and first
we're gonna make use of centroids very
common terminology and a lot of machine
learning languages when we're grouping
things together so we're going to make
use of centroids which is the average of
its points and you can see here we're
gonna take the 1 2 and the 2 1 and we're
gonna group them together because
they're close I mean if we were looking
at all the points we look for those that
are closest and start with those and
we're going to take those two we're
gonna compute a point in the middle and
we'll give that point one five one point
five one point five and that's going to
be the centroid of those two points and
next we start measuring like another
group of points we got four one five
zero when they're pretty close together
so we'll go ahead and set up a centroid
of those two points in this case it
would be the 4.5 and 0.5 would be the
measurements on those two points and
once we have the centroid of the two
groups we find out that the next closest
point to a centroid is over on the left
and so we're going to take this and say
oh zero zero is closest to the 1.5 1.5
centroid so let's go ahead and group
that together and we compute a new
centroid based on those three points so
now we have a centroid of 1.1 or 1 comma
1 and then we also do this again with
the last point the 5/3 and it computes
into the first group and you can see our
dendogram on the right is growing so we
have each of these points are become
connected
we start grouping them together and
finally we get a centroid of that group
too and then finally the last thing I
want to do is combine the two groups by
their centroids and you can see here we
end up with one large group and you'll
have its own centroid although usually
they don't compute the last centroid we
just put them all together so when do we
stop combining clusters well hopefully
it's pretty obvious to you in this case
when they all got to be one but there
are actually many approaches to it so
first pick a number of clusters K up
front and this is done in the fact that
we don't want to look at 200 in clusters
we only want to look at the top five
clusters or something like that so we
decide the number of clusters required
in the beginning and we terminate when
we reach the value K so if you look back
on our clustering let me just go back a
couple screens you'll see how we
clustered these all together and we
might want just the two clusters and so
we look at just the top two or maybe we
only want three clusters and so we would
compute which one of these has a wider
spread to it or something like that
there's other computations to know how
to connect them and we'll look at that
in just a minute but to note that when
we pick the K value we want to limit the
information that's coming in so that can
be very important especially if you're
feeding it into another algorithm that
requires three values or you set it to
four values and you need to know that
value coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay
only three clusters that's all we want
for K so the possible challenges this
only makes sense when we know the data
well so when you're clustering with K
clusters you might already know that
domain and know that that makes sense
but if you're exploring brand new data
you might have no idea how many clusters
you really need to explore that data
with let's consider the value of K to be
two so in this case in our previous
example we stopped when we are left with
two clusters and you can see here that
this is where they came together the
best while still keeping separate the
data the second approach is stopped when
the next merge would create a cluster
with low cohesion so we keep clustering
until the next merge of clusters creates
a bad cluster low cohesion setup on
there that means the point is so close
to being between two clusters it doesn't
make sense to bring them together but
how is cohesion defined oh let's take a
little deeper into cohesion the diameter
of a
cluster so we're looking at the actual
diameter of our cluster and the diameter
is the maximum distance between any pair
of points in the cluster we terminate
when the diameter of a new cluster
exceeds the threshold so as that
diameter gets bigger and bigger we don't
want the two circles or clusters to
overlap and we have radius of a cluster
radius is a maximum distance of a point
from centroid we terminate when the
radius of a new cluster exceeds the
threshold again we're not we don't want
things to overlap so when it crosses
that threshold and is overlapping with
other data we stop so let's look at
divisive clustering remember we went
from the bottom up now we want to go
from the top down divisive clustering
approach begins with a whole set and
proceeds to divide it into smaller
clusters so we start with a single
cluster composed of all the data points
we split it into different clusters this
can be done using a mono ethic divisive
methods what is a monolithic divisive
method and we'll go backwards and let's
consider the example we took in the
agglomerative clustering to understand
this so we consider a space with six
points in it just like we did before
same points we had before and we name
each point in the cluster so we have in
this case we just gave it a letter value
ABCDEF since we follow top-down approach
and divisive clustering obtain all
possible splits into two columns so we
want to know where you could split it
here and we could do like a be split and
a cdef split we could do BCE ADF and you
can see this starts generating a huge
amount of data
ABCDEF and so for each split we can
compute cluster sum of squares and we
can see here the actually have the
formula out for us bj 12 equals n1 of
absolute value of x minus absolute value
of x squared so again we're computing
all the different distances in there
squared back to your kind of Euclidean
distances on that and so we can actually
compute BJ between clusters one and two
and we have the mean of the cluster and
the grand mean depending on number of
members in the cluster and we select the
cluster with the largest sum of squares
let's assume that the sum of squared
distances largest for the thirds
we head up above and that's where we
split the ABC out and if we split the
ABC out we're left with the D EF on the
other side we again find this sum of
squared distances and split it into
clusters so we go from ABC we might find
that the a splits into B C and D into EF
and again you start to see that
hierarchical dendogram coming down as we
start splitting everything apart and
finally we might have a splits in B and
C and then each one gets their own d EF
and it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or until we get to K
if we have set a K value so we've kind
of learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math in
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive in to a demo and our demo today
is going to be for the problem statement
we're gonna look at u.s. oil so a US oil
organization needs to know it sells in
various states in u.s. and cluster the
states based on the sells so what are
the steps involved into setting this
problem up so the steps we're going to
look at and this is really useful for
just about any processing of data
although I believe we're going to be
doing this in our today we're going to
import the data set so we'll explore our
data a little bit there create a scatter
plot it's always good to have a visual
if you can once you have a visual you
can know if you're really far off in the
model you choose to cluster the data in
or how many splits you need and then
we're going to normalize the data so
we're gonna fix the data up so it
processes correctly we'll talk more
detail about normalization when we get
there and then calculate the Euclidean
distance and finally we'll create our
dendogram so it looks nice and pretty
and we have something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money in salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up our and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really has some nice features in it it
automatically sets up the three windows
where we have our script file on the
upper left and then we can execute that
script and it'll come down and put it
into the console bottom left and execute
it and then we have our plots off to the
right and I've got it zoomed in
hopefully not too large a font but large
enough that you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data and we're
going to assign it in R this is a symbol
for assigning and we're going to go read
CSV read CSV file and I'll put that in
brackets let's before we go any further
let's just look at the data outside of
our it's always nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities CSV this would also be the
time to get the full path so you have
the right path to your file and remember
that you can always post in the comments
down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on you can repeat it and see how
this works
this is utilities dot CSV it's a comma
separated variable file so it's pretty
straightforward and you can see here
they have the city fixed charge and a
number of different features to the data
and so we have our our our cost low
demand cells nuclear fuel cost on here
and then going down the other side we
have US cities Arizona Boston they have
central US I guess they're grouping a
number of areas together the
Commonwealth Area you can see down here
Nevada and New England northern US
Oklahoma the Pacific region and so on so
we have a nice little chart of different
data they brought in
and so I'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities dot CSV
and we're gonna import that file let me
just enlarge this all the way up side an
extra set of brackets here or somehow
maybe I missed a set of brackets this
can happen if you're not careful you can
get brackets on one side and not the
other or and there's a case I got double
brackets on each side there we go and
then the magic hotkeys in this case are
your control enter which will let me go
ahead and run the script and so I've now
loaded the data and as you can see I
went ahead and shrunk the plot since
we're gonna be looking at the window
down below and we can simply convert the
data to a string now all of us do this
automatically the first time we say hey
just printed all that as a string and
then we get this huge mess of stuff that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense so
when you can see here they have you can
probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head now we'll do the head
of my data there we go and control enter
on that and the head shows the first
five rows you'll see this in a lot of
different scripts and are it's you type
in head and then in brackets you put
your data and it comes through a list of
first five rows as you can see below I
mean it shows Arizona Boston Central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the RoR
the cost the load the D demand I'm not
an expert in oil so I'm not even sure
what D demand is cells
I'm guessing nuclear how much of it
supplied by nuclear and the actual fuel
cost
and then the different states at-ats an
or different areas and one of the
wonders of our is all these cool
easy-to-use tools that are so quick so
we'll do pairs
and pears creates a nice graph so let me
go ahead and run this whoops the reason
it gave me an error is because I forgot
to resize it so let me bring my plot way
out so we can see it and let's run that
again and you'll see here that we have a
nice graph of the different data and how
it plots together how the different
points kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
I would look at this and say hey this is
a great candidate for some kind of
clustering and the reason is is when I
look at any two pairs let's go down to
say cells and fuel costs towards the
bottom right and when you look at them
where they cross over you sort of see
things how they grouped together it's a
little confusing you can't really
pinpoint how they group together you
could probably look at these two and say
yeah there's pretty good commonalities
there and if you look at any of the
other pairs you'll start seeing some
patterns there also and so we really
want to know what are the patterns on
all of them put together not just any
two of them the whole set up let me go
ahead and string my this down for just a
second just a notch here and let's
create a scatter plot and this is simply
just use the term plot in brackets and
then which values do we want to plot and
if we remember when we looked at the
data earlier let me just go back this
way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
to just two values to see how they look
now I'll do fuel cost in cells and it's
in my data so we let her know which two
columns we're looking at next to each
other and it will open up our plot thing
and then go ahead and execute that and
we can see on those close up of what we
were just looking at in the pair's
and if I was eyeballing this I would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and this one it's
hard to tell which cluster would be with
that maybe it's six to go in the top one
and you have a middle cluster and a
bottom cluster may be two different
clusters so you can sort of group them
together fuel cost and the cells and see
how they connect with each other and
again that's only two different values
we're looking at so in the long run we
want to look at all of them and then the
people in the back they sent me the
script so we can go ahead and add labels
so with my data.txt fuel cost cells the
labels equals City position four
these are numbers you can kind of play
with till they look nice and whoops
again I forgot to resize my plot it
doesn't like having it too small and
we'll run that
I must type something in here oh I did a
lowercase D and they did a capital D
there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see a little
hard to see on my screen with all the
the different things in there it plus
the actual cities so we can now see
where all the cities are in connection
with in this case fuel cost and cells so
have a nice label to go with the graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do oh the RoR whoops
and we'll do that
also with the cells and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two we'll come over
here and it's going to surprise it and
give me an error
and then we'll also add in the with
statement so we put some nice labels in
there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the fuel cost
cells we want the our cells will execute
that oops and of course that gives me an
error because I shrunk it down so let's
redo those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the RoR with cells and we probably get a
slightly different clustering here if I
was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together and
those kind of go together but again
we're gonna be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive in
to the next step where we gonna start
looking at a little bit of coding or
scripting here
this is very important because we're
looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any of the other machine
learning skills and setup dishes start
to look very normal in your
pre-processing of data whether you're in
R or Python or any of these scripts we
really want to make sure you normalize
your data so it's not biased remember
we're dealing with distances and if I
have let's say the RoR is even look at
this graph here on the right you can see
where my RoR varies between 8 and 14
that's a very small variable and
ourselves varies between 4,000 and
16,000 so you can imagine the distance
between 4,000 and 8,000 which is a
distance of 4 thousand verses 8 to 10
verses to the cells is going to dominate
so if we do any kind of special work on
this it's gonna look at cells and it's
going to cluster them just by the cells
alone and then ror might have a little
tiny effect of 2 versus 4000 we want to
level the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize so I'm just
going to put in the code that they put
together in the back for me and let's
talk about it a little bit so we have Z
we're going to sign it to my data
and it's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows or I mean across all
columns so you to the rosin kind of a
little reshaping there and then we're
going to get em which stands for means
and we're going to apply it to my data
so again we want to go ahead and create
a the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be the SD stands
for standard deviation so instead of
just doing a lot of times what they do
with normalization of data is we just
reshape the data everything between zero
and one so that if the lower end is
eight that now becomes zero and the
upper end is fourteen that now becomes
one
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data so with this we're gonna
look for the means and the standard
deviation for reshaping the data and
that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation to be equal amongst all of
them and then finally we go ahead and
take Z and with the Z we're going to
reassign it and we're gonna scale the
original my data which we shaped based
on M and based on the standard deviation
and the two in here that just means
we're looking at everything in kind of a
XY kind of plot
and we can quickly run these
control-enter ctrl enter ctrl enter ctrl
enter so now we have Z which is a scaled
version of my data and now we can go
ahead and calculate the Euclidean
distance
oops calc you there we go
and in our this is so easy once you've
gotten to here we done all that pre data
processing we'll call it distance and
we'll assign this to
distt Saudi ist is the computation for
getting the Euclidean distance and we
can just put Z in there because we've
already reformatted and scaled Z to fit
what we want let me go ahead just hit
enter on that and I'm gonna widen my
left hand side again I'm always curious
what does this data look like so let's
just type in distance which will print
the variable down below
oops if they hit control enter and this
prints out a huge amount of information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and I don't know about you but when I
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than I see
two three four five six and then you
kind of have the top part six 17 18 so
imagine this is like a huge chart is
what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print o
distance digits
[Applause]
equal three and let's run that helps to
keep forgetting that it has to go
through the graph on the right and we
see a different slightly different
output in here let me just open this up
so we can see we're looking at and by
cutting down the distance you can start
to see the patterns here that's looking
at the different distances so if I go to
the top we have the distance between 1 &
2 1 & 3 1 & 4 1 & 5 1 & 6 and then 2 & 3
so on obviously the distance between a
self is zero and it doesn't repeat the
data so we don't care to see two versus
one again we already know the distance
between 1 & 2
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits
well let's just do to see what that
looks like we might lose some data on
this one if it's uh if something's way
off but we have a nice set up and we see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points and then the whole reason
we're doing this is to get ourselves a
nice dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable HCl and we're
going to assign it H cluster and then
distance that easy we've already
computed the distances so the H
clustering does all the work for us and
then we hit enter on there so now we
have our HCl which is assign the H
clustering computation based on
distances and apart and then I'm gonna
expand my graph because we would like to
go ahead and see what this looks like
and we can simply plot that
and hit the control-enter so it runs and
look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendogram except when I look
at it the first thing I notice is it
really shows like numbers down below now
if you were a shareholder and some data
scientist came up to his head look at
this this is what it means you'd be
looking at that going what the heck does
3 9 14 19 118 mean so let's give us some
words there
so let's do the same plot with our HCl
HC there we go and let's add in labels
and this is just one of the commands and
plots so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city and we'll have it hang minus
one that's just the instructions to make
it pretty so we'll run that oops
accidentally ran just to hang my one let
me try that again
there we go okay so now you can see what
it's done and the hangman one turns it
sideways that way we can see central
which is central u.s. and Kentucky and
we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup and
the information you start looking at is
that we put all the information together
you probably want to look at Central
American Kentucky together Oklahoma and
Texas has a lot of commonality as does
Arizona and southern us and you can even
group all five of those Florida Oklahoma
Texas Arizona and southern us these
regions for some reason share a lot of
similarities and so we want to start
asking what those similarities are but
this gives us a place to look it says
hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do this is also we can do the
dendogram average this changes how we do
the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and those are HCl we're going to
assign it we're gonna do an H cluster
we're still doing it on distance oops
distance and this time we're going to
set the method to average so we can
change the methodology in which it
computes the values and before if you
remember quickly we did median medians a
little bit different than means we did
the most common one and then we want the
average of the median and let's go ahead
and run that
and then we can plot and here's our HCl
oops there you go here's our HCl and I
can run that plot and you can see this
changed a little bit
so our way it computes and groups things
it looks a little different than it did
before and let's go and put the cities
back in there and do the hang control
copy
let me just really quickly copy that
down here because we want the same
labels and again you can see Nevada
Idaho Pooja
I remember we were looking at southern
US and Arizona Texas and Oklahoma
Florida so the grouping really hasn't
changed too much so we still have a very
similar grouping it's almost kind of
flipped it as far as the distance based
on average has but this is something you
can actually take to the shareholders
and say hey look these things are
connected and at which point you want to
explore little deeper as to why they're
connected because they're gonna ask you
okay how are they connected and why do
we care that's a little bit beyond the
actual scope of what we're working on
today but we are going to cover
membership what's called a clustering
membership on there
and let's create a member we'll just
caught member one upstairs
remember dot one and we're going to
assign to this
we're going to do cut tree and cut tree
it limits it so what that means is I
take my 8c dot L in here
oops there we go ow and so I'm taking
that cluster I just built and we want to
take that cluster and we want to limit
it to just a depth of three so we go
ahead and do that and run that one oops
let me go run there we go so now I've
created my member one and then whoops
let me just move this out of the way
we're gonna do an aggregate and we're
going to use Z or Z from above and we're
going to turn number one into a list and
then we're going to aggregate that
together based on the mean let me go
ahead and enter run that
I did remember L it's actually number
one there we go
and if we take a look at this we now
have our Group one fixed charge and then
all your different columns listed there
and most of them should come up kind of
looking between zero and one which
you'll see a lot of variation because
we're varying it based on the means so
it's a means the standard deviation not
just forcing it in between zero and one
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values and the same chart we just
did
oops
I made a mistake on there with my data
there we go okay
and again we now have our actual data
instead of looking at just the if you
looked up here it's all between 0 & 1
and when we look down here we now have
some actual connections and how far our
distance this different data is again
because more of a domain issue and
understanding the oil company what these
different values means and you can look
at these as being the distances between
different items so a little bit
different view and you have to really
dig deep into this data we really want
you to take away from this is the
dendogram and the charts that we did
earlier and that is the cluster output
and our nice dendogram so this would be
stage 1 in data analysis of the cells
again you'd have to have a lot more
domain experience to find out what all
the individual numbers we looked at mean
and what the distance is and what's
difference between Central America and
Kentucky and why they're similar and
Wyatt groups all of central Kentucky
Florida Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
southern us together into one larger
group so I'd be way beyond the scope of
this but you can see how we start to
explore data and we start to see things
in here where things are grouped
together in ways we might not have seen
before and this is a good start for
understanding and giving advice for
sales and marketing maybe logistics city
development there's all kinds of things
that kind of come together in the
hierarchical clustering as you begin to
explore data and we just want to point
out that we get three clusters of
regions with the highest sales region
with average sells region with the
lowest sales again those are what some
of the things that they clustered it
around and you could actually see where
things are going on or lacking you know
this is case if you're the lowest sales
no one wants to be in the region of the
lowest sales so the key takeaways that
we cover today is we went over what is
clustering we did the hierarchical
clustering and the agglomerative and
divisive the two terms that we learned
today we mentioned partial clustering so
partial clustering doesn't have the
dendogram you don't know the doesn't
have that tree look appearance it just
has things grouped together and we
didn't talk about k-means or fuzzy simi
because that's going to be a different
tutorial not in the scope of this one
but certainly get an idea of what K
stands for is how many breaks you want
and we talked about the hierarchical
clustering itself in the example with
the cars when we looked at hierarchical
clustering and how it works and the
three different steps where we measure
the distance we continue to group the
objects and we find a point to where we
terminate we stop working so we don't
have a continual loop and we look deeper
into the agglomerative clustering where
we group each object starts off as its
own group and we keep grouping them
together based on the distances between
them and we look at the device of
clustering we found the best place to
split the groups or going the other way
and then we covered a demo in our on
hierarchical clustering and in this case
had to do with oil cells and different
aspects in the oil industry thank you
for joining us today for more
information visit www.un.org/webcast
let us know what you're thinking and if
you have any questions again thank you
very much for joining us today and happy
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here